[Music]
it may surprise you
that the most illegally trafficked mama
in the world
is not the elephant
or the rhinoceros
it is a small gentle
scaled mammal called a pangolin
very few people have heard of pangolins
and fewer still have sent them in the
wild
[Music]
they are the only scaled mammals on
earth
pangolin scales are prized by many as
remedies to cure
everything from cancer
to infertility
despite the fact that there is no
scientific proof for this
as the supply of asian pangolins has
dwindled
traffickers have increasingly turned to
africa as a means of satisfying the
demand
[Music]
i'm dr mark
i'm a veterinarian
we have a shelter and to the best of my
knowledge it's the first animal shelter
in nigeria
in my cause of rescuing these wild
animals i stumbled on the pangolin
when i look at the pangolin it's a very
beautiful creature
when you look into the eyes you see
old man's wisdom yes he's very
intelligent that's the pangolin
[Music]
up till about a couple of years ago i
didn't even know
we have pangolins in nigeria
this is because they've been so haunted
and threatened you don't get to see them
ordinarily
i don't see the trader as a bad person
at that level
it is a means to an end
they are trying to survive
hunting and bushmeat selling is their
family vocation nobody has told them
otherwise
when you try to tell hunters these
animals are on the brink of extinction
they will laugh at you and tell you that
look that's impossible
these people have this understanding
that the animals were put in a forest by
god
our nature for us to eat they don't have
that concept that animals can go extinct
the traders see it as a way to earn an
income for their families
i sell bushmeat so i buy from the hunter
and i sell in an open market
[Music]
when i did an investigation last year i
realized that
the traders most of them are now when
that scales have been trafficked to asia
they don't have that knowledge
[Music]
30 years we have been doing the
training now
[Music]
if you can buy one pangolin for 12 000
naira some hunters rather sit down and
be looking for pangolins
so that they can feed their families
they don't know the costs
they get like zero zero one percent of
the entire deal
so they are being cheated
these people basically are victims of
the circumstance they find themselves in
and these people are good people
they trade that they do this to be able
to care for their kids
they don't have any evil intent
[Music]
in my course of practice i got to notice
some things cultural
the average nigerian has this notion
on wild animals which is basically bush
meats
[Music]
despite the fact that it's against our
practice to buy when i see an animal
that is worth rescuing if it's living if
it's breathing i'm going to take it
knock knock knock karo
when they see mark come in and buy
pangolin
most of them know that he won't kill me
and i'm sure they would think this is
weird
how can somebody just come into the
market buy an animal then go and give it
back to nature i mean it's weird that's
the way nigerian will think five
thousand there that's the price
wow okay but when you are in love with
wildlife you find out that there's
nothing wrong with that
calm down you're feisty
okay everyone
i might not be able to get all the
pangolins
but for that one that i'm able to rescue
it's a difference between life and debt
yes
trading pangolin is illegal so i hope
and i pray we get to the point where
we'll be making raids at the bush market
to stop the trade of pangolin
completely but without backing up the
authorities there's nothing i can do
corruption is not new to nigeria
it has made nigeria the
hub for this illicit trade
where i see corruption happening
i just have to put an ad out there
we've seen adverts on twitter we seen on
facebook you do an e-transfer
once they receive some money then you
take it down to the seaport
grab some custom officials
they allow them to go through the system
for nigeria we're not just supplying the
international trade we're also a transit
point coming from other areas into the
country and then getting out of the
country from nigeria
so that's a major problem
we're against nigeria being a hub
we're not at that place we want to be or
we're making progress
last year they had the largest record
seizure globally
over 14 000 metric tons of pangolin
skills
so it tells that things are getting
better i think nigeria will make
progress
corruption has placed us to become a
body to biodiversity
nathan come on over i want to show you
something
sit down sit down
i want to show you about this animal
my boy is eight years old and he is
picking up my interest in wildlife yes
you see it's a very gentle animal he met
some pangolins yes and he's intrigued by
them because they are quite unlike
anything he's seen before yes
now that we have rescued them from these
hunters you know we can't keep him so we
take this pangolin to the protected
forest where no hunters go to
that's called rehabilitation
coming back
okay
last week i did another foray to the
markets and we found about six
hangul lanes
he was bringing them out of the basket
we had
large sized ones and then we had this
tiny little baby pangolin
there and then i had already made up my
mind that we were taking them with us
we won't leave them behind
[Music]
because of the value that has been
placed on the scales from other
countries majorly asia these hunters
they now go into the bush
for pangolins if we are able to kill
that demand
then you will see that the sourcing of
the pangolin will die naturally then
we have done releases in the past but we
have never ever released six at a time
we're very hopeful that these ones will
breed hair
and then we can have more in the
ecosystem
she's seen bush everywhere all around
her and she just
wants to go
this is so beautiful
it was a bit heartbreaking getting to
leave the cute little one but he's going
to leave
he has a whole forest to himself and
maybe someday he's going to be the king
pangolin of the forest
and who knows i could be lucky enough to
meet him
on none of my hikes in a forest yes
[Music]
so
[Music]
you